Some of you will have seen Sean and me
going wild around Bletchley Park and will
deduce from that that we paid a visit to BP
as they call it in the trade.
It's time now for me to move off from the
Enigma story which I've done
two or three videos on already, and tell a story
that in many ways is
even more relevant to the start of
computer science than
even Enigma was. We've all heard of
Alan Turing but
I would suspect that fewer of you
have heard about Bill Tutte,
Max Newman, Tommy Flowers. But they're all
worthy of hero status because they're all
connected with a type of
cipher traffic - mysterious cipher traffic -
that came to Bletchley Park's attention and
at Bletchley was always called Tunny traffic.
They loved calling mysterious traffic by
the name of fish and there were things like
Sturgeon and Halibut as well as Tunny. But
this one is going to be
Tunny traffic. Tunny is the original
English word for what we nowadays call
Tuna - it's as simple as that.
Even before the war the Metropolitan
Police
and the Foreign Office, jointly, used to
listen
to the airwaves to see what was happening
- you know, that shouldn't be happening
within the UK shores. Anything mysterious.
Now an awful lot of course of what they were
listening to
was plain straightforward radio
broadcasts or,
from the military point of view, it would
be Morse code. Some of that Morse code
might well be
encrypted Enigma traffic, but it
was in Morse. This one was weird
it wasn't in Morse it sounded almost
like
a touch-tone telephone on steroids or
something,
It was "meeeooow", "meeeooow" all over the
place
And so what they did was they equipped
the listening stations, all over the
UK,
because they all knew that war was
almost inevitable;
they had a whole load of joint listening
stations and these listened for Enigma
traffic.
They also listened for anything unusual -
they were called Y stations -
capital Y -
for reasons I don't understand, but there
again Bletchley Park was called Station X
and I don't understand that either. So
these Y stations started saying:
"Look there's some weird stuff here would you
like to see what it looks like?"
They were able to make a recording of
the trace of this,
as if it was an oscilloscope but
actually on a piece of paper
If you look here it's like a waveform
and that is exactly what it is
and they were able to record this as a
black
trace and when you look at it, it's like a
mixture between a sort of
sine wave and a square wave. But once they got
the experts in looking at this --
you've  got to remember teleprinters were
very common
they were used in stock exchanges, they were
used in telegraphy. A
lot of traffic went over land-line
that was actually teleprinter code. This
was broadcast
because presumably the land line was too long
between
the far end of Greece and Germany,
let's say.
So it had to be broadcast and the
experts said
"That's broadcast teleprinter traffic,
that is!". Now you know why Sean and I
have set
the scene by doing a video already on 5-hole
paper tape codes,
the teleprinter alphabet and even
on exclusive-OR.
The rule at the Police and the Foreign
Office was that anything mysterious like this
gets sent to GC&CS.
We remember from the previous videos
GC&CS
(Government Code and Cipher School) -  initially
based in Saint James's Park in London
but the great majority of it moved off to
Bletchley Park in the late Thirties.
So Bletchley Park was accumulating this
stuff. Big debate:
"Is this a Vernam Cipher?"
In the late nineteen twenties an
American
employee of AT&T had come up with the
idea
of doing secure, enciphered
teleprinter transmissions by doing
what we would now call
an exclusive-OR between two
five-bit patterns. Yeah?!  Great idea
because it would disguise the character you
wanted to send ...
There's only one problem that if you want to
apply that to a whole message
how would you arrange
to have, as it were, cipher key
characters - randomly chosen -
to mix in, via exclusive-OR, with
your plaintext that you wanted to send
and to send out the result? Well, what
Vernam proposed - and to my amazement
he patented it. And you think: "This is madness!
This is madness! This is secure! they
shouldn't be patenting this stuff - it gives the
game away !"
This is AT&T and we're not at war
yet!  We're not having the competition
coming up with this bright idea. This has got
commercial potential, you know, as well as
military.
We're gonna patent it. So Vernam
patented the idea.
It would use two five-hole tapes and
what you could do is have this one,
which is the plaintext, running alongside
this one
which has somehow been generated and this
is the key.
This is the thing that's going to be
exclusive-OR'd,
character by character, with this to give
a cipher text.
The problem is the enormous one - these
things are driven by sprocket holes.
You start trying to run two tapes
simultaneously
through a piece of bespoke electronics, which
they invented, which would do the merging
but you must keep them in exact sync. You
do not want differential stretching
between the two things. Worse still when
your supervisor says "This thing isn't going
fast enough, we need more speed!" and you
speed it up
you know what happens next -  the sprocket
holes tear. And then you've got slippage
like you never dreamed of in your worst
nightmares.
So, as a result all this problem of
tape
synchronization it never really got to
market.
It was quietly abandoned,
but the idea was good. But the people at
Bletchley Park started saying:
"Is this a Vernam cipher
that we were taught about at training
school before we started here at BP?"
But maybe the Germans have been smart
enough to say we're not going to use the
second tape
because you've got to get it synchronized. We will
provide
the key characters from a machine. It'll
be like an
add-on to the teletype - the teleprinter.
You type in your plaintext character
this thing we'll invent and it's probably going
to have
wheels - rotor wheels - every good cipher
machine has rotor wheels on it -
will somehow generate a 5-bit
International Teletype letter and then
it'll automatically
exclusive-OR it and then we'll get an output
and that'll be our cipher and the good thing
is that it will be a lot less problem to
keep the machine
in sync with what we're doing when you've
only got one tape
to worry about. So in the end they
discovered that that's
exactly what was happening - looked at
more and more of this Tunny traffic:
How on earth are we ever, ever, going to get
into this stuff ?
At the start of this signal it goes up
high
but the rule in these intercepted
messages, that were put out on this
piece of kit called the Undulator, is that if
it's high it's a zero
and if it goes low it's a one and the
neutral point is somewhere in the middle.
Let's just do a straightforward addition
of two 5-bit
codes to see what it would look like. The
letter A - capital A -
in the International Teleprinter code -
the Baudot-Murray code -
is one one zero
zero
zero and let me remind you one of the
approved signals for
doing an exclusive-OR operation is a plus
in a circle.
I'm going to add that on via exclusive-
OR
to the letter X. Letter X is
one zero one one one
You all know how this works now
exclusive-OR
gives a 0 if they're the same
and a 1 if they are different. Look that up
in your table - what character is that? - its
the letter V.
So there we are look. The plaintext
shall we say was A, the ciphering character given by
the randomizing device was X
and this particular character is V.
What we're going to have to do
on this, surely, is to get enough evidence
about that random key stream before we
can start working out how the heck it
works.
Mathematicians were around, were
upon the scene,
arguably not as many as Bletchley Park
really needed in the early days,
to say: "Look, this is an example of what we
in the Mathematics trade call an
Additive Ciphering system.
It's doing arithmetic modulo a certain
number.
This as I've said is arithmetic modulo two
it's binary addition, but without the
carries.
And some wise soul said; "You know there
are weaknesses in all additive ciphers.
Basically, at the end of the 19th century,
a man called Kerckhoffs had published a
paper
about cryptography via additive ciphers
and said the problem with them
all is
if you accumulate enough captured
ciphertext, even when you don't know
the key, but
lots of different messages, if they're all done
with the same
key you can eventually accumulate so
much that via a
clever trick you can work out what the
messages are
without even
knowing the key, because it kind of cancels
out.  Oh! that could be helpful!
So all we've got to look out for then
is are they using the same key for any of this
stuff?
Handy! Every single one of
these transmissions, before it came through on
the Undulator -
they all came with an Indicator.
Now this really puzzled them at
first. I've
copied one down, from my reference books.
Those 12 characters would be sent out
and then there'd be a pause.
And then this stuff, the Undulator
traffic would start.
However there was sufficient of this
sent out, to train the operators, that
again the game was given away.
The cryptanalysts said: "I wonder if that's
in code or cipher itself - oh! i dunno -
but, you see, could this be like
Enigma?
They sent out blocks of three letters
to show
the settings - the initial settings. Could
it be like that ? "
Then somebody else would say: " Yeah but there's
twelve of them - that doesn't make
sense;
ten would make sense - two layers of encipherment
one after the other
First row of five, y'know, five bits
and then push it on again - do another one.
But these could be settings of
cipher wheels just like Enigma. But how
can we be sure that they aren't
in a code of their own. Do they really mean
what they say? As part of the training
scenario
obvious to the poor operators trying
to work this machine
there were some of the transmissions that said
`in clear'
"M ist Michael"
"G ist Gerhard", Right?!  So by the time you got
"O ist Otto", "K ist Karl"
you can see this is training the operators:
"Yes, it's K for Karl,
you see the K and you wind the cipher wheel round
until you see
letter K for Karl and by the fact
that they
had elaborated, in the training, all of
these as
boys' first names made
the listeners sure that these were what they
seemed.
So the answer now is very clear, we have
to sit and wait patiently;
we have to ask our Y stations to
rigorously send us
exactly what the Indicator was, and if
we wait long enough
somebody will use the same Indicator
twice.
Absolutely against standing orders but it
was known from Enigma this was a great
temptation in the heat of battle,
with people shouting at you, to use the same
settings
twice. "It's alright - nobody will be
listening. Hmmm! Oh yes they are ... "
This did happen, I guess you could say,
sooner rather than later. I think it was
August 1941
they finally got a message which had got
the same
indicator and they knew perfectly well
that with that and
with a lot of hard, patient, work - because there were
no computers to help you -
nevertheless we can probably disentangle
this message.
Now, another thing, these messages seemed to
be going between headquarters
of the German High Command. These were not
between weather stations
they were not even between Luftwaffe
stations, this was
serious stuff.  This was going from
Athens HQ to Berlin HQ,
shall we say. Clearly this stuff - and there
wasn't much of it initially -
was going to be used by the high-ups - the
German High Command.
As we now know it really was Hitler's
favourite cipher machine.
It's great advantage, unlike Enigma,
was that it was user-friendly. You know what
Enigma's like:  you need a person to
punch the thing
a person to read the lamps, a person to send
the Morse code.
Here you could connect two encrypted-type
teletypes back-to-back, across a
land-line
or even across the airwaves, although
that would be a bit
dicey to do with interference. But you
could in principle
have your operators never see the
ciphertext It goes in one
end, ... enciphered ... across ... deciphered
out it comes. Therefore
because it's easy to use, and user-friendly,
people would send
longer messages and that's music to the
ears of the cryptanalyst brigade
they loved that! By this stage the
listeners had decided that we needed
a new Y station, separately for this
Tunny traffic - remember the traffic was
called Tunny
the machine that was generating it was
called German Tunny - or just
Tunny. The machines that eventually they built at
Bletchley Park, once they understood how
it worked,
to do the same job of deciphering, was
called British Tunny -
but it was all Tunny. So here
was this Tunny traffic
all stacking up, all waiting to be
decrypted,
all waiting for two or more
to be sent out with the same key.  Now
at Bletchley, technically, that's called
a "depth". Getting a depth means you've got two
or more messages
all with the same key. Absolutely against
standing orders,
because the German cryptographers had warned
the military
that this one - this kind of XOR additive
cipher -
is even more sensitive to depths
probably even than Enigma. With Enigma you
only got a short message out anyway
because
life's too short to send much more
than about 50 characters.
This thing - in the end - they got 4000
characters-worth
and then, when the chap
phoned back "Sorry!  didn't
quite get that, could you send it again ?!"
My first thought was surely the sender
guy would have had the
sense to make a tape of it and send it
off-line in the first place?
No, he hadn't. He'd typed it in by hand without
making a copy.
So when it was sent again you can
imagine the sender
muttering and cursing. He used
abbreviations; he made it shorter
and as we'll see, next time, that
made the deciphering job even easier